so what do you say to the critics who
say oh it's not a big issue it's being
you know enhanced by
conservatives and people in media who
want to make this a talking point and
we're really only talking about a couple
hundred athletes here and uh people
should just stop making this bigger than
it is what is your response to those
critics
I want those critics to look at myself
and other female athletes who have
dedicated their entire lives to
perfecting their craft because that's
what it is and say that and mean it
because yes it's not happening
um you know there's there's not
necessarily uh stories of domination I
mean there are but that's a lot of the
argument but this happening to one
athlete is one athlete too many and this
is something that will increase it's
underreported there's lots of instances
that aren't even being talked about and
so it's not transphobic
um if this was just simply a biological
male or I guess someone who's not
transitioning I wouldn't be okay with it
um so if it was you know no matter what
this is when you're putting yourself in
a situation where you're
have unfair advantages that you can
never overcome no matter what you do no
matter how much training you put in
um it's wrong it's unfair and it doesn't
make me transphobic for believing so
talk to me about the athletic governing
bodies if you had a message that you
could send to them directly what would
that be
um well I think the piece I want to hit
on is the lack of accountability like I
mentioned earlier there is no one
willing to
face this issue head on
um directly and say exactly how they
feel it's been a lot of beating around
the bush it's been turning to other
organizations
um and since you know doing this
especially the NCAA
um
they nominated well you Penn nominated
Thomas for NCAA woman of the year which
was then approved by the NCAA which is
the highest honor in all of college
sports and to nominate someone who has
spent five percent of their life as a
female is wrong we're encouraging that
we're celebrating that then sobble is
praising this and it's absolutely wrong
and sending the wrong message to young
girls
um to pass female athletes who had to
fight for Title IX and to present female
athletes
what has been the media reaction you
said you have gotten a lot of support
and I've seen some of that unfold even
when I announced that I was going to be
talking to you today there were a lot of
people who were really excited and very
supportive of what you've been saying
um what has the negative reaction have
you heard from woke media have you
gotten messages you know what does that
look like
um because we have to be realistic you
know somebody who does come out and
speak out like you is going to face the
rash of people who just don't like to
scent in any in any respect what does
that look like for you and has that in
any way ever made you regret your
decision to speak out
no I definitely don't regret my decision
um but actually I've gotten one of the
comments I've gotten a lot is you only
do right wing media you'll only go on
Fox News blah blah blah
um I've actually reached out to
different left-winged media to just
increase the audience who hears my
message and I have been shot down by
every single one of them they are not
willing to have this conversation with
me
um
and so I think a lot of my support has
been because I'm preaching to people who
already agree with me but when trying to
speak with people who don't it doesn't
get me very far because people aren't
willing to listen
um I actually went on Dr Phil last I
think I don't I don't think it's aired
yet but I did it last week to try and
increase that audience because I think
it's important I think more people who
are
um kind of on the fence on the political
Spectrum which I hate that this is even
political
um they need to hear this they need to
hear the facts behind this because I
wholeheartedly believe that it will be
Republicans who fix this issue
yeah and unfortunately everything's
political these days even I know you
don't want to be political it just it
just balloons and and that's not
surprising to me at all uh people in the
audience you know it's not surprising to
me that left-wing media doesn't want to
talk to you
um and there's a reason why which is
that you're very well spoken first of
all you have facts on your side reality
we don't live in the land of fiction
some of us you're very well spoken and
you're somebody who has done the work
and has trained and the last thing they
want to do is face somebody like you
they're not prepared for that debate and
they don't want to lose in front of
their audience so they're just simply
not going to have the conversation with
you that's why that's happening it's sad
but it's a reality I look forward to
that Dr Phil interview I think he at
least attempts to put people of
different opinions on and have that
conversation which is very important if
you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
foreign
[Music]